i know i'm very excited about this
former first daughter and author chelsea
clinton she's written nine books for
young readers they help teach kids about
everything from endangered animals to
activism and gutsy women in history her
new book is called i love this welcome
to the big kids club it answers
questions children ask when a new baby
joins their family like can my baby see
me why does my baby sleep all the time i
love that they call it my baby chelsea
clinton is the mother of three kids vice
chair of the clinton foundation an
executive producer of the new
docu-series gutsy with her mother her
mother by the way is hillary clinton
good morning to you chelsea full
disclosure i just bored chelsea with
pictures of my favorite and older lucas
so this this topic i think is really
great
was because i know eventually they would
like to have another baby but i remember
when favorite daughter kirby was born 11
months older 11 months later her
favorite son my favorite son will came
she took a look at him in one of those
little baby things and then just flipped
the thing over oh no
and the attitude was how long is he
staying right and when can i return yeah
when are they going back yeah even at 11
months there's something that they know
when a new baby comes it changes the
dynamic in the family absolutely and so
you wrote this book wide to address all
of those things thank you gail yes so i
wrote this book kind of in my head um
when i was pregnant with
jasper our third because
charlotte and aiden our first two were
four and three and they had so many
questions um about the new baby and as
soon as jasper was born charlotte um who
was four
you know would say well like my baby i'm
like well yeah baby i was like well
actually it is our baby it's your baby
like a little kid
this connection to your
baby brother and still the conversations
just continued after
you know jasper was home and i finally
thought we can't be the only family who
are having these conversations
and whenever i have that thought that
rattles around persistently i think oh
well i have to write a book yeah but
it's fascinating to me chelsea because
you're an only child i am and yet you
have three children of your own
did you go through life thinking i wish
i had a sibling was that your story i
did i really wanted
well i first wanted an older brother
yeah me too um and then i realized you
may be in kindergarten i was like well
that can't really
just a younger brother or younger sister
and my
mom has spoken about how they did try to
have another child and we're not able to
and i do have a memory gale of maybe
being
eight or nine and thinking oh i should
stop asking like this is painful for my
parents yes yes
only child only child only child
i grew up in a household boys i'm the
oldest poor girl
and i'm the oldest of four girls and i
always wanted an older brother so i can
relate to that and he's four boys yeah
so i want to go back to the advice for
parents so advice first is you know buy
the book it will help
it will help ease the path uh what other
advice do you have for families who are
gonna walk uh welcome a new addition
into the family you know i think really
to listen to our kids so that it doesn't
feel like this is being imposed on them
although of course it sort of it is but
you know listening to them listening to
their questions their their concerns so
they do feel like this is a family
decision this is a family kind of
journey of our family being expanded i'm
being honest when we don't know the
answers you know when i was talking to
other kids not just my kids
about kind of what they would want to
see in the book you know i got asked a
question like well you know when can the
baby get its own pet like oh well you
know i don't know and you should
definitely talk to your parents about
whether you're gonna get a pet i know um
don't blame chelsea clinton
you're like well she said i could get a
vlog
so just being candid about what we know
and what we don't know and what we're
going to discover together about our new
baby one of the other challenges for
parents is there's the new baby in the
family but then that baby grows up and
at a certain point there's a new adult
in the family and as a parent you've got
to deal with your children as
full-fledged people on their own potty
trained as you say unemployed yeah
what's your relationship like with your
mom these days as you've become an
independent person potty trained denim
yeah i mean i am assuming i don't know
you know feel free to assume that i
think thankfully tony
i have such a good relationship with my
mom i am so
proud of what we've done with gutsy and
i also just had so much fun working with
her as an adult and it just candidly
felt like such a gift um to be able to
do that during covid to spend this
really special time together when i know
so many families were separated and
we got to be able to do this work
together was just
so joy-producing every day
that's awesome what is hillary clinton's
grandma name that my uh children call my
mom grandma and my dad pop-pop and what
kind of grandmother is she oh very
hands-on does she give advice
do you like she i don't know if she
gives advice directly to my children but
she gives me a lot of advice and
sometimes i'm like thank you so much
sometimes i'm like that was like circa
1980 yeah we don't do that i get that
too i get that too thank you chelsea
always good to see you thank you so much
the name of the book is welcome to the
big kids club it's on sale wherever you
like to buy your books we'll be right
back